CHIN FOR HOW WE EXITED
AFGHANISTAN.
I'M NOT WALKING AWAY FROM THAT.
PEOPLE BEING MERIT AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT WHO DIDN'T MAKE THE
DECISION.
>> WELL, WELL, WELL, SHE SAID
SHE WAS THE LAST PERSON IN THE
ROOM.
>> SHE WAS THE LAST PERSON IN
THE ROOM, BUT THE PERSON WHO
BUCK STOPS WITH THE PRESIDENT O
THE UNITED STATES.
IT WOULD BE THE SAME AS SAYING
DONALD TRUMP MADE IT SWEET IN
BLAMING MIKE PENCE FOR THAT
TWEET.
>> DID MIKE PENCE SIGN OFF ON
THE TWEETS.
SHE SAID SHE WAS PART OF THE
POLICY.
>> FAIR, BUT ONCE AGAIN, IF YOU
GOING TO HEAP CRITICISM ON
ANYBODY YOU HEAP IT ON THE
PERSON WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES THE PERSON WH
IS THE ACTUAL COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
.
OVERDOING IS SEGMENT ON KAMALA
HARRIS AND.
>> NO ONE IS BLAMING HER, IT
JUST HAS THE STENCH OF FAILURE
WAFTING OVER TO HER HAIR.
AND SHE IS NUMBER TWO.
REMEMBER THE PLACEHOLDER?
>> CLOSE, BUT NO CIGAR.
IF YOU WANT TO BLAME JOE BIDEN,
ABSOLUTELY.
>> THEY NEED TO KEEP HER AWAY
FROM HIM SO SHE DOESN'T GET
STAINED AND SO THAT SHE.
>> I WILL END ON THIS, HOW MANY
TIMES DID THE MEDIA OR ANY
DEMOCRATS THEY WHERE IS PENCE.
WHERE IS PENCE ON ALL OF THIS
WHEN TRUMP WOULD SAY OR DO
SOMETHING.
IN WILBUR TALKING THE ONE WOMAN
OF CALIFORNIA WHO VOTED AGAINST
THIS ALL FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> THE WOMAN WHO IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT IS BRIEFED REGULARLY
ON THE UNFOLDING SITUATION IN